اخبار حرب غزه بايجاز من مستشفى شهداء
الاقصى اهلا بكم بعد اعلانها نجاح جهود
الوساطه لابرام اتفاق هدنه مؤقته قطر تقول
ان الاتفاق سيكون ساريا خلال الساعات
القادمه نتنياهو جدد الالتزام
بالهدنيا مقابل افراج اسرائيل عن 150
امراه وطفلا فلسطينيه عشرات الشهداء
والجرحى في قصف اسرائيلي لمنازل في انحاء
غزه كما استهدف الاحتلال الدفاع المدني في
بيت لاهيه وانذر المستشفى الاندونيسي
بضروره الاخلاء من جهتها اعلنت وزاره
الصحه في غزه وقف التنسيق مع منظمه الصحه
بعد اعتقال الاحتلال مدير مجمع الشفاء
وعددا من الكوادر الطبيه شهيد في مواجهات
مستمره مع قوات الاحتلال في مخيم بلاطه
بالضفه الغربيه الجيش الاسرائيلي حاصر
المخيم وقام بحمله اعتقالات واسعه في حين
قال نادي الاسير الفلسطيني ان قوات
الاحتلال اعتقلت 90 فلسطينيا في الضفه منذ
الليله الماضيه وعلى الجبهه الشماليه قصف
متبادل بين اسرائيل وحزب الله الحزب قال
انه استهدف اليات وقوات اسرائيليه بشكل
مباشر والجيش الاسرائيلي يعلن اطلاق عشرات
الصواريخ من لبنان على البلدات الشماليه
ويقول ان الهجوم هو الاوسع منذ بدايه
الحرب الى
اللقاء